a human body has 5 litres of blood
40% of which is red blood cells each red
blood cell has a volume of approximately
90 times 10 to the negative 15 liters
how many red blood cells are there in a
human body write your answer in
scientific notation and round to two
decimal places so they tell us that they
tell us the total volume of blood in the
human body we have we have five liters
so we have five liters and then they
tell us that 40% of that 40% of that is
red blood cells so if we take the five
liters and we multiply by 40% this
expression right here gives us the total
volume of the red blood cells 40% of our
total volume of blood now this is a
total volume of red blood cells and we
divide by the volume of each red blood
cell then we're going to get the number
of red blood cells so let's do that
let's divide by the volume of each red
blood cell so the volume of each red
blood cell is 90 times 10 to the
negative 15 liters liters so let's see
if we can simplify so one thing that we
can feel good about is that the unit's
actually do cancel out we have new
liters in the numerator leaders in the
denominator so we're going to get just a
pure number which is what we want we
just want how many red blood cells are
actually in the body so let's just focus
let's just focus on the numbers here so
five times 40 percent well five forty
percent is the same thing as 0.4 so let
me write that down
this is the same thing as 0.45 times 0.4
is two so our numerator simplifies to 2
and in the denominator we have 90 times
10 to the negative 15 which isn't quite
in scientific notation or actually it
definitely is not in scientific notation
it looks like it but remember in order
to be in scientific notation in order to
be in scientific notation this number
has to be greater than or equal to 1 and
less than 10 it's clearly not less than
10 we can convert this to scientific
notation very easily 90 is the same
thing as
nine times ten or you can even say nine
times ten to the first and then you
multiply that times 10 to the negative
15 and then this simplifies to this
simplifies to 9 times 10 to the well
let's add these two exponents 10 to the
negative 14 10 to the negative 14 10 to
the negative 14 and now we can actually
divide and let's simplify this division
a little bit this is going to be the
same thing this is going to be the same
thing as 2 times as 2 over 9 is 2 over 9
x times 1 over 10 to the negative 14
well what's 1 over 10 to the negative 14
well that's just 10 to the 14 so this
right over here is just the same thing
as 10 to the 14 now you might say okay
we just have to figure out what 2/9 is
and we're done we've written this in
scientific notation but you might
already realize look two ninths is not
greater than or equal to one how can we
make this greater than or equal to one
well we could we could multiply it by 10
if we multiply this by 10 then we've got
to divide this by 10 to not change the
value of this expression but let's do
that so this is equal to if we multiply
so I'm going to multiply this by 10 and
I'm going to divide this by 10 so I
didn't haven't changed I've multiplied
and divided by 10 so this is equal to 20
over 9 20 over 9 times 10 to the 14th
divided by 10 is 10 to the 13th power so
what's 20 over 9 this is going to give
us a number that is greater than or
equal to 1 and less than 10 so let's
figure it out and they wanted us to
round I think they said round our answer
to two decimal places so let's do that
so 20 divided by 9 9 doesn't go into 2
it does go into 20 2 times 2 times 9 is
18
subtract get a remainder of 2 I think
you see where this show is going to go
get a remainder of 2 9 goes into 20 2
times 2 times 9 is
18 we're just going to keep getting twos
so we get another to bring down to zero
nine goes into 20 two times so it's
really this thing right over here is
really 2.2 repeating but they said round
to two decimal places so this is going
to be equal to two point two two times
ten to the 13th power